today's the day and hopefully everything
goes well
[Music]
[Music]
it's her back and then turns into a wide
right yeah Coco
okay and then we could just then that's
like snagged close-ups once she's in her
place this is as she's walking oh as
she's walking okay gotcha
I'm Kevin J when I'm a video producer
here at BuzzFeed and I've been here for
around two and a half years a type of
content I generally like to make here at
BuzzFeed are social impact Asian
identity videos and just like videos
that are overall fun what we're working
on now is a Chinese zodiac fact video
and this is kind of like a huge fashion
type video we have twelve models coming
in it's gonna be tore it's gonna be
elaborate makeup elaborate hairstyles
and it's just a lot going on all at once
it's gonna be crazy cable like you just
go to Walgreens and get one but we'll
see how it is for now okay yeah I'll let
you know are we good to go
almost you're gonna walk your hands out
and then you're gonna walk all the way
here turn around on your mark and then
go with that okay and let's go through
this shot and action
so we have 12 models they're gonna
represent one of the Chinese zodiac
signs and so they're gonna be
essentially surrounded by all these
floating lanterns in pitch black that is
what I'm envisioning and they're just
gonna look super fierce super amazing
super hot so the inspiration from all
three collection combines is talking
about the deep emotions that represent
the female figure strong independent and
the value of a female young guy am human
man hung wanking about named living
young hidden guy
yeah the weekly Carl Icahn game last
pose so somehow we ended up wrapping
early today and I'm like what the heck I
came into today thinking like oh god
something's gonna go wrong something's
gonna get us off schedule and in fact we
actually went above schedule and we were
able to get all six models for day one
completely finished before half the
day's over everybody today just brought
their a-game and I'm just feeling very
very grateful
[Music]
we're ready for our first model oh I'm
so excited
Wow imagine that your limbs are just
like water great as you're moving so
just very like slow but sultry and just
really milking every move that you've
got all right so we have the dragon in
there her costume looks freakin amazing
the only thing is it's really big so it
does constraint minutes a little bit we
have the designer in there kind of doing
some final touches just so that she
feels a little bit more comfortable but
it is slowing it down a little bit I
think we'll be fine I think we'll be
fine so we were in the middle of filming
the dragon and coincidentally the fire
alarms went off and I thought this can't
be happening right now and then I had to
get everybody out of the building I'm
like oh god is there actually a fire
here
[Music]
it's like real turns out it was our fog
machine
are there any shots or sensitive lien
gifts to help alleviate some of this and
then do a fresh load coat below the
studio team had to be brought in
everybody who's air security was there
they were like what was the problem I'm
like there's no problem we're just
shooting a fashion fitty help I mean if
you guys are good with this planner
diaper check to make sure it's still a
favorite and now we are fanning the room
out I don't know how that's gonna affect
the rest of the day and our schedule I
production is being halted right now and
I don't know what's gonna happen for the
rest of the day the reason why I'm
taking on this project is because I've
always wanted to do this I've always
thought man I don't know if I have oh it
takes to do like this huge production
coronate such a huge cast a huge crew I
know for me like Eugene has created this
path for a lot of producers here and
he's just made a name for himself by
doing content like this and I've always
respected him I've respected his work
and I've always felt like man I want to
be able to do that and so this is kind
of like one of my milestones as it
creative and it's like really
nerve-wracking and I don't know what's
gonna happen but I hope I can make it
work
what's the protocol moving forward for
the rest of the day should we just you
should be completely fine right now
because the mitigation is in place we're
both ventilating we have fire watch you
don't have to worry
I think a lot of times when we think
about buzz we think about like taste
tests and like really funny over-the-top
stuff and yes we do have that but if you
really think about it we also have some
really amazing nuance pieces in social
commentary to what we're creating here
is essentially a high production video
about agent culture and we don't often
see that in mainstream media and I
wanted to create this because I know
BuzzFeed can reach millions of people
and those millions of people we're able
to shape their frames of references so
if they've never been exposed to like
Asian culture or Chinese culture Chinese
zodiac this is an easy digestible way of
them to learn something and it's just
something that anybody can watch and
consume and be like wow that's so cool
and by normalizing what Asian identity
looks like that it's so cool and not
just whatever mainstream media has
thrown out there I think that's really
awesome and that's what I really want to
do nailed it yes and I think that's a
wrap although that it is stressful that
at the end of the day I know this
product will come together and come
together great because I have a lot of
amazing support behind it thank you to
everybody you all were wonderful models
DP grip everybody you guys killed it I
just want to be able to release this
video and have numerous amounts of
people whether you identify as Asian or
not you're able to consume this video
and be like wow this is amazing and I
want more of this I want people to crave
more content like this
[Music]